this morning we're bringing you
something new it's called the uplift at
eight and it's where we share stories
that we bring you some joy to start your
day vlad has today's edition vlad hello
so sometimes the things that bring the
most joy seeing others experience it
right we can all agree to that that is
the case for this this college-bound
student take a look at this
you got it cynthia
wait really
oh my god
that is cynthia obifuna and her mom
finding out that cynthia's hard work has
paid off the 17 year old was selected
from hundreds of applicants to be part
of the inaugural class of the kipp rails
scholars program the scholars are chosen
based on academic achievement
perseverance leadership potential and
commitment to service each receives 60
000 for college and gets mentoring and
career guidance kips is a nationwide
network of public charter schools 88 of
their students are from financially
disadvantaged communities cynthia who
loves science plans to double major in
neuroscience and human rights at
columbia university roar lines roar
cynthia is amazing she founded an
initiative that pairs young scientists
with other scientists in their chosen
field so that they can be just like her
i love the program sixty thousand
dollars is a big chunk for your college
it's a life changer yeah that's a lot of
money they're not have that debt means
it's it's more than 60 really because if
you took out 60 in loans it would be 120
in 10 20 years exactly right big deal
vlad thank you very much i do feel
uplifted
too do you feel a little uplifted folks
we'll see we're going to be here every
day we'll see you or someone we know
back with another i'll be here all week
all right